[Música]
eles dizem que é difícil mundial ganhar
mas com ronaldo o melhor do mundo dá pra
acreditar
o patrício na baliza nada vai entrar com
este futebol no mundo vai ter que parar
não vou desligar a nossa seleção vai
jogar ao lado de outros três
mas tem de cortar e hoje vai ter de
saltar o nosso e não vai esquentar o
elemento de dos estados trilho quaresma
é um safado do trigo é puro gozo
ele joga gostoso ele jogar gostoso que o
turno da tarde que o ronaldo faz o golo
e choca gostoso eu enxergar gostoso na
defesa temos o pedro eu não é maldoso
pelo jogamos todos os pêlos jogar
gostoso toca à bomba como tinho e idoso
ele joga
é gostoso ele jogou gostoso e vai tornar
dn cruza bem devagarinho disso vai se
temos de tratar a bola com carinho
gonçalo lo
cuidado que essas diferenças vão fazer
de tudo para separar vou desligar não é
só vai julgar e de outros três que vai
ter de cortar vai ter de saltar o nosso
e não vai cantar nem tudo está destruído
eo quaresma é um safado de trivela é
puro gozo ele jogar gostoso e jogadas
tosu future melo da tarde que o ronaldo
faz gol ele choca gostoso e jogá gostoso
né defesa temos um tempo eu não é
maldoso e jogando gostoso vê-los jogar
gostoso toca a bola com moutinho e ela é
do idoso ele joga gostoso
ele joga gostoso
pelo jogam pelo jogam
eu e jogam jogão custoso pela jogam pela
jogam pelo jogam e o quaresma é um
safado e trivela é perigoso ele jogar
gostoso ele jogar gostoso que o fenómeno
da tática o ronaldo faz o gol ele choca
é gostoso eu jogar gostoso né defesa
temos o pedro
ela não é maldoso ele jogar gostoso pelo
jogar gostoso toca bom moutinho e leve o
idoso ele jogar gostoso ele jogando
gostoso
somos mais dois milhões em campo com
vocês vamos mostrar a garra do nosso
povo romano salvatti
mundo portugal 80